many Americans coming home from abroad
waited in very long lines for several
hours and major airports have medical
screenings people as you see were packed
together shoulder-to-shoulder despite
the CDC's call for social distancing
Kris Van Cleave is at Reagan National
Airport that's just outside Washington
DC Chris those lines were very jarring
to see the last thing you need at the
airport these days so what's being done
to prevent these lines from forming
again well good morning Gail that's your
exactly right this is exactly what
Americans are being told to avoid the
acting Homeland Security Secretary says
they are working to increase capacity
and speed up the wait times but take a
look at some of this video we know that
very long lines and long wait times hit
at least three of the 13 airports
screening passengers returning from
Europe Saturday night this follows
travel restrictions going into effect
from most of Europe the UK and Ireland
are being added to that list now these
social media pictures show a crowded
Chicago O'Hare waiting for hours the
slowdown appeared to be a combination of
staffing the new health screenings and
new forms passengers have to fill out
yesterday a flyer returning from Finland
on a virtually empty flight described
confusion getting back into the u.s. our
experience getting home was one of
everything going on time although every
time we'd ask a question like what's it
going to be like when we get back to the
US no one could answer it and we knew it
was rapidly changing because we were
seeing the headlines about what was
happening at O'Hare Americans coming
back from Europe China Iran are being
asked to self quarantine once they get
home for 14 days President Trump is
telling Americans if they don't have to
travel not to and that is causing
Airlines to start shedding capacity a
United Airlines said overnight they
would cut 50% of their capacity by April
they're facing the possibility of losing
at least a billion dollars 1.5 billion
dollars this month alone yes Chris
they've said it's worse than 9/11 thanks